nobody saw these flicks coming from an
MCU darling trading his Avengers buds in
for some furry friends to a 21st century
take on a buzz worthy horror classic
these are just some of the most
surprising unexpected and straight-up
bizarre movies hitting theaters in 2020
Doctor Dolittle is a character with a
weird history the physician who could
talk with animals was created by author
Hugh lofting in letters written home to
his children from the trenches of World
War one the character would go on to
become the star of a series of popular
children's books set in Victorian
England and published from the 1920s
through the 50s a number of adaptations
appeared over the following decades
including cartoons radio plays stage
productions and a lavish 1967 movie
musical starring Rex Harrison when
modern audiences see the name Doolittle
however they probably think back to the
1998 movie starring Eddie Murphy which
became something of a franchise all its
own spawning such intriguingly titled
direct DVD sequels as tail to the chief
now the good doctor is returning to the
big screen in the form of wait for it
Robert Downey jr. the animal cast will
be voiced by a star-studded lineup that
includes Remmy Moloch John Cena
Emma Thompson Octavia Spencer Tom
Holland Selena Gomez and ray Fiennes we
know exactly what you're thinking where
in the world did this one come from we
don't exactly have an answer for you but
after over a decade rocking that Iron
Man suit maybe our DJ just needed to
lighten things up a little bit it is the
destiny of all horror franchises to be
rebooted that's been the case for pretty
much the entire 21st century so far
since the dawn of the new millennium
we've seen remakes and re-imaginings of
the Texas Chainsaw Massacre a Nightmare
on Elm Street Friday the 13th and
multiple stabs pun intended at a new
Halloween
another long dormant series seems ready
for similar treatment Candyman released
in 1992 was based on a story by
Hellraiser creator Clive Barker and star
Tony Todd as a supernatural killer who
haunted a housing project in Chicago and
represented the specter of racial and
class inequality also bees came out of
his mouth it's weird and socially
conscious and freaking awesome but she
said his name the last time Candyman she
turned out the lights and it's perfect
material for the shockingly prolific
Jordan Peele who is producing and
co-writing a new Candyman slated to hit
theaters in 2020 Bloody Disgusting
reports that the film directed by
up-and-comer Nia decosta will be a
spiritual sequel that returns to the now
gentrified neighborhood of the original
casting remains unannounced but Todd is
angling to be involved in some capacity
one of the most intriguing cinematic
developments of 2018 was the launch of
Sony's new generation of spider-man
movies having successfully partnered
with Marvel to bring Tom Hollands
live-action Peter Parker to the MCU the
studio has set out to keep their own
stake in the Spidey brand alive with a
slate of spin-offs and animated titles
the first two examples venom and into
the spider verse proved that they were
ready to explore a variety of unique and
vastly different facets of the web heads
corner of the Marvel Universe work
quickly began on sequels to both venom
and spider-verse though no firm dates
for those follow-ups have been
officially announced Sony has however
confirmed a 2020 release for Morbius
starring the quote living vampire who is
faced off with spider-man in comics
since the 70s
no we didn't see that one coming either
daniel espinosa is on board to direct
with the script by Dracula untold
writers Matt sasame and Burke Sharples
Jared Leto will star as the titular
bloodsucker with former Doctor Who actor
Matt Smith appearing in a major role and
true detective star Adria Arjona as love
interest Martine Bancroft coming to
America was released in 1988 at the
height of Eddie Murphy's superstardom
Murphy who co-wrote the story stars as
Prince Hakeem heir to the throne of the
fictional African nation of
Munda determined to escape an arranged
marriage and find a free-thinking bride
to fall in love with he travels to New
York City with trusted aid semi in tow
it was a box-office smash capping off an
explosively successful decade for Murphy
I've warned you I'll be forced to thrash
you you after a period of rumors and
rumblings that coming to America sequel
has been officially announced and set to
be released in 2020 you heard that right
Hakeem is coming back to America after
30 years and this time he's searching
for his long-lost son original
supporting players Arsenio Hall Shari
Headley John Amos and James Earl Jones
are all rumored to be in talks as well
blackish creator Kenya Barris is penning
the screenplay with Craig Brewer taking
the director's chair from the original
movies John Landis not only our Roald
Dahl's stories enduring works of
literature they've also been adapted by
a staggeringly eclectic lineup of
filmmakers Steven Spielberg Tim Burton
Wes Anderson and Danny DeVito to name a
few in 2020 Robert Zemeckis will join
that lineup with a new take on the
witches this 1983 children's novel tells
the story of an orphan boy who goes to
live with his grandmother
a retired witch hunter the pair must
battle an international coven of witches
poised to turn England's children into
mice the witches has been made into a
movie once before in 1990 that
production had a stellar array of talent
with acclaim director Nicolas Roeg at
the helm Jim Henson on board as producer
and a delightfully wicked performance
from Angelica Huston the film was
received enthusiastically by critics
though Dahl enraged by alterations to
his story called it quotes utterly
appalling Zemeckis witches is already
shaping up to have an impressive
pedigree of its own not only is the man
behind back to the future in Forrest
Gump taking on writing and directing
duties but Guillermo del Toro and
Alfonso Curran are producing and Anne
Hathaway is attached to star as the
Grand High Witch the witches will
enchant theaters in the 2020 Halloween
season check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
a single one
[Music]